[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi en ce début d'année
focus sur la reconversion
professionnelle voici le sommaire
changer de voir repartir à zéro en 2010
est d'en mode d'emploi vous avez pu
écouter plusieurs personnes qui ont fait
le choix de changer d'orientation et de
se former un nouveau métier et des
démarches qui nécessite bien souvent un
accompagnement christiane buisson
directrice de la cité des métiers à
traquer al qatif en consultant le bilan
de compétences aussi baissé soixante dix
huit seront avec nous en plateau
témoignages également de jeunes
accompagnés par les missions locales de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de plaisir
et si en 2018 vous changez de métier
depuis ces dernières années la
reconversion professionnelle est choisi
par de plus en plus de français au cours
d'ailleurs de nos émissions mode
d'emploi nous avons rencontré des
personnes qui ont franchi le pas petite
rétrospective novembre 2010 est d'en
mode d'emploi nous vous parlions des
métiers du numérique avec la formation
community manager chez i fuck up à
montigny le bretonneux une formation
suivie notamment par des personnes qui
avaient choisi de se réorienter
comme en
mon précédent ton poids j'étais office
and facility manager d'un grand groupe
d'un centre d'excellence de formation et
au sein de ce groupe une restructuration
et donc j'ai été amené à être sur le
marché du travail et lors de mes
recherches j'ai constaté plusieurs
annonces ou ont recherché des
responsables du service sont troupe qui
est l'équivalent de bons titres en
anglais avec des compétences d'un
community manager je fais une licence en
marketing qui auquel j'ai pas été formés
aux métiers du numérique où tout ce qui
est l'aspect technique
donc c'est pour ça que ça compléter
parfaitement mon cursus parce que c'est
le but quand même de l'ifocop c'est de
nous prédisposé aux métiers du numérique
mais est la clé obtenir un emploi qui
vont lui permettre d'entrer
définitivement pardon dans le digital se
former un nouveau métier en 2017 c'était
également le souhait de caroline et de
hamza au lycée louis blériot à trappes
avant j'étais dans la restauration dans
le tourisme j'étais un peu pas mal de
choses et puis j'ai décidé que quand
j'ai décidé c'est
d'aider les gens voilà clairement c'est
ce que je préfère m'occuper des gens les
aider
et donc voilà je me suis dirigé vers ce
moment j'ai arrêté l'école après mon
bébé donc j'ai travaillé ensuite assez
tôt en tant que brancardier ensuite
guichetier ensuite j'ai été beaucoup en
usine manutentionnaire magasinier tout
ça puis bah j'ai voulu changer de camp
je devoir complètement et donc je me
suis tourné vers l'assistance aux
familles et puis je regrette pas et pour
entamer ces démarches de reconversion
des organismes existent avec nos
plateaux christiane buisson bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice de la
cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines on la présentera d'ailleurs
dans quelques instants en face de vos
âmes capitan bonsoir à vous soit vous
êtes consultant de bilan de compétences
aux cibc 78 alors le cibc c'est le
centre interinstitutionnel de bilan de
compétences des yvelines est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus oui alors le
cibc 78 et donc implanté dans les
yvelines et en fait appartient au réseau
à une fédération du réseau national des
cibc en fait il y à un cibc par
département on est à dos et nous sommes
adossés à l'éducation nationale donc on
et organismes publics à caractère
commercial est en fait notre nos
prestations fallait les services que
nous apportons sont essentiellement le
bilan de compétences mais on est aussi
sur le champ de l'orientation des jeunes
coaching orientation jeunes des
prestations d'accompagnement des cadres
avec le pôle emploi sur des appels
d'offres du pôle emploi et puis
également sur de la veille
on y reviendra justement vous parlez de
vo on y reviendra dans quelques minutes
christiane bus en quelles sont les
missions de la cité des métiers dont qui
est implanté à travers une cité des
métiers c'est un espace un lieu
ressource un espace d'accueil pour
toutes les personnes qui se questionnent
sur leur vie professionnelle donc la vie
professionnelle c'est assez large et ça
peut aller depuis l'école le collège
jusqu'à l'âge de la retraite on reçoit
des personnes qui viennent pour préparer
leur retraite et avoir un complément de
revenu pour la retraite une cité des
métiers dans une cité des métiers ont
peut être reçu en entretien individuel
sur notre espace conseil par des
conseillers on peut venir utiliser un
espace multimédia faire ses démarches en
d'autonomie sur les ordinateurs
on peut s'inscrire on a une
programmation d'ateliers on peut
s'inscrire à des ateliers thématiques et
puis on peut venir aussi s'informer sur
les métiers à travers divers événements
lorsque l'on veut entamer une
reconversion une réorientation ils font
bien sûr respecter quelques étapes on va
en parler d'ailleurs dans quelques
minutes avec vous juste avant je vous
propose de regarder les témoignages de
plusieurs jeunes qui auront été suivis
par les missions locales de notre
territoire
il s'appelle mamadou maria françois est
native âgés entre 16 et 25 ans ils ont
tous un point commun ils sont suivis par
les missions locales de 50 ans on y vit
les deux plaisirs instance créée des
heures au siège de la mission locale et
si vous venez tous les jours avoir
d'avoir commis le patron barre du coup
on faisait
les cv des motivations déjà commencé en
alternance au septembre dernier le 14 et
du coup d'épicés jour là et maintenant
j'entends de fermat déjà mal et en
alternance l'année dernière j'étais en
terminale
scientifique à la fin de l'année je me
suis rendu compte que ce n'était pas ce
que je voulais faire et il y avait trop
de théorie jeux venus voir la mission
locale de plaisir qui m'a
qui m'a aidé à choisir le filière
gestion et administration
je pense que bac pro gestion
administration va me permettre
d'acquérir tous les compétences
nécessaires pour pouvoir gérer une
structure toute seule j'ai été mis sur
mon cas et tout le monde était bien
sympa avec moi et du coup c'est là que
je me suis inscrit et trouver un
conseiller qui s'appelle le sait jean
yves germain cap1 2016 et là maintenant
j'ai un travail j'ai connu en mai son
local au mois d'août
ils m'ont aidé et m'ont aidé à trouver
mon entreprise
ils m'ont ils nous on a des filles à
trouver d'accord financièrement avec le
club du plaisir rugby club
je suis en tant que animateurs je suis
super rabat ses brevets d'aptitude
professionnelle d'assistant animateur
technicien
c'est tout ce qu'il ya de l'animation
mais je veux plus tard je veux viser
plus haut le bpjeps pour être éducateur
sportif et dans mon club je fais
plusieurs choses je peux faire les trucs
comme les tâches ménagères ou aussi
j'entraînais les enfants de 8 à 17 ans
en tout 5000 jeunes comme nati françois
ou maría sont suivis par les missions
locales de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
de plaisir qui viennent tout juste de
fusionner kristen cuisson est ce qu on
sait pourquoi finalement les les gens
veulent se réorienter veulent veulent
entamer une reconversion professionnelle
alors il peut y avoir plusieurs
plusieurs causes pour qu'on se réoriente
déjà en premier lieu parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de métier qui évolue qui
changent certains métiers disparaissent
dont que certaines personnes se
retrouvent confrontés à cette
problématique et sont un petit peu forcé
de devoir réfléchir à un nouveau projet
il peut y avoir des accidents de
parcours des arrêts maladie un peu long
on entend beaucoup parler de burnout
donc voilà ça fait une cassure dans le
parcours et on se repose des questions
autrement et
voilà on souvent souvent la solution
c'est de changer on peut avoir envie de
changer parce que je sais pas une
certaine lassitude
oui une certaine lassitude
souvent on revient aussi à ses premiers
rêves on est beaucoup de personnes qui
qui ont un certain nombre d'années
d'expérience d'expérience et puis qui se
disent mais quand j'étais jeune je
voulais voilà et on se repose aussi ces
questions là il peut y avoir des
problématiques liées à des
délocalisations des rachats aujourd'hui
encore à la cité des métiers
j'ai reçu deux personnes qui étaient
confrontés à cette situation la notion
de métier tend à disparaître et ça on
réfléchit autrement aussi à son projet
professionnel la notion de métier
aujourd'hui tandis prête à disparaître
au profit de la notion de compétence et
du coup ses compétences on peut les
mettre en oeuvre dans plein de deux ans
plein de possibilités pour aller mettre
en oeuvre ses compétences et puis aussi
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que par
rapport à l'orientation des jeunes il
faut plus penser
penser je vais choisir mon orientation
etc pour toute la vie non c'est voilà
c'est plus comme ça que ça fonctionne
maintenant il faut bien se dire qu'on
fait un choix à un moment donné pour
quelques années et qu'après on va
rencontrer d'autres opportunités
il va y avoir des
des changements voilà tout va un petit
peu vite et que forcément on va exercer
certainement plusieurs métiers dans sa
vie donc la formation continue c'est
important tous les dispositifs avait eu
bilan de compétences il faut voilà
justement le capitan parlons de 7,2 ce
bilan de compétences à quoi sert-il
alors lubie le bilan de compétences
comme des et christiane les demandes
sont très très variés finalement il rit
il
il sert à beaucoup de choses selon les
attentes de la personne qui demande un
bilan bien souvent c'est vrai comme
disait christiane il ya vraiment une
cassure il ya une recherche de
remobilisation fait les personnes
cherche vraiment à se remobiliser
c'est vrai quand on est dans son métier
depuis plusieurs années finalement on se
rend même plus compte qu'on exerce des
compétences tellement enfin les choses
on les fait au quotidien on se rend même
plus compte que c'est des compétences
donc c'est vraiment de remobiliser cette
connaissance de compétences de ses
capacités ce sur quoi alors l'expression
j'ai souvent avec mes bénéficiaires
c'est on descend de son vélo et on
regarde tout ce qu'on a pédalé point sur
des parcours de 20 25 ou 30 ans et ça
permet vraiment c'est une pause sur ce
parcours et de se réapproprier cette
meilleure connaissance de soi et
d'ailleurs dans la première étape du
bilan de compétence et bien toute
orientation démarre par une meilleure
connaissance de soi donc c'est de
revisiter
voilà déjà ce mieux se connaître en fait
pour mieux gérer sa sont le montage de
ces scénarios parce que c'est vrai que
dans le champ d'à de réflexion et
d'études de l'orientation parle plus de
projets enfin le terme tend à
disparaître
et on appelle ça plutôt des scénarios
aujourd'hui des scénarios imaginer des
scénarios professionnelle voilà et de
plus être sur un seul thème un seul
chemin était en fait c'est aussi
s'autoriser à rêver à nouveau
he has et à voile a éventuellement entre
ouvrir des portes
et regardez qu'est ce qui est possible
aujourd'hui une dernière question un
conseil que vous pourriez peut-être
donner aux téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent et qui veulent justement se
réorienter se reconvertir
professionnellement parlant
un grand cei rapidement ap le bilan de
compétences est ouvert à tous les gens
les gens ne me connaissent vraiment le
dispositif
donc il ya des prises en charges
financières
voilà il faut se rapprocher donc de son
autre cas des organismes paritaires
collecteurs de fonds enfin voilà qui
sont rattachés à l'entreprise et on peut
bénéficier d'un bilan de compétences en
que son employeur soit soit forcément au
courant parce que ça peut déstabiliser
mais c'est un vrai un vrai chemin une
vraie phase exploratoire en tout cas
pour se permettre enfin voir deux de se
dire que rien n'est figé
voilà moi c'est si je peux lancer ce
message c'est ça les cinq buts en un
conseil pour les décès venir à la cité
des métiers où on peut rencontrer entre
autres capitan et d'autres collègues du
cibc et d'autres d'autres partenaires
aussi qui travaillent sur le champ de la
reconversion professionnelle donc il a
cité des métiers
accès libre gratuit anonyme voilà et
puis toutes les infos sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran merci mesdames d'avoir été
présente sur notre plateau alors
l'émission touche à sa fin mais avant
jetons un rapide coup d'oeil sur vos
prochains rendez-vous justement la cité
des métiers attrape organise mardi 23
janvier un atelier intitulé valoriser
vos qualités professionnelles c'est de
9h30 à 11h30
inscription obligatoire au 01 34 82 82
61 et puis si vous souhaitez en savoir
plus sur les métiers des travaux publics
par l'apprentissage
rendez vous le mercredi 24 janvier à la
cité des métiers toujours à trappes de
14 heures à 16 heures inscription
obligatoire au 01 34 82 82 61 voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve le mardi 30
janvier pour un mode d'emploi consacré
cette fois ci aux métiers de la sécurité
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]